Hello there.
Awhile back, I got a letter from a fan
who lives in South Korea.
Her name is Sunny Lee.
She invited me to visit her country.
She wrote this very long, detailed letter,
and she wrote it on her SAT prep form.
She said she can't prepare for her SATs
'cause she's too busy watching
episodes of my show.
Sunny also sent a bunch of cool Korean snacks.
Tons of them.
So I decided to visit Sunny in person to thank her.
That's when I found out
that even though my show does not air in Korea,
thanks to the Internet, I have some fans there.
(speaking in Korean)
(fans cheering)
(audience clapping)
(yelling in Korean)
(fans screaming)
I love Korea!
(audience laughs)
Oh my god, it's so beautiful.
Right here?
Sunny Lee!
Ohh! (fans chanting)
Sunny Lee invited me.
Sunny Lee, thank you so much.
I'm going to go to my hotel now
and shower because I stink.
All right, hi, how are you?
Oh hi, how are you?
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Oh my god.